hello everyone
welcome to archives libraries and
databases in taiwan
this is the second webinar in our
three-part series doing chinese history
in a new era
this series is organized by myself
denise ho at yale university and emily
baum at uc irvine
and it has been generously sponsored by
the council on east asian studies at
yale university
and the long u.s china institute at uc
irvine
we are also very grateful to our
co-sponsors for helping to promote and
support these webinars
they include harvard university's
fairbanks center the center for east
asian studies at stanford university
the project on globe china's global
sharp power at the hoover institution
the center for asian research at york
university the department of history at
simon fraser university
the institute of asian research at the
university of british columbia
the east asian studies program at johns
hopkins university the east asian
studies program at uc santa cruz the
global china center at hong kong
university of science and technology
and the hong kong institute for the
humanities and social sciences at the
university of hong kong
some of the presenters will be speaking
in chinese but if you'd like to type
your question in english
that's fine too in total the webinar
should last for approximately 90 minutes
and it'll be recorded in case you can't
stay until the end
we'll send out the link to the youtube
video in a follow-up email
to all registered participants so as
most people
are aware gaining access to mainland
chinese archives
has gotten progressively more difficult
in recent years and kobit 19 has only
exacerbated the situation
in last summer's edition of this webinar
series
two of the three of our webinars
addressed the challenge of
accessing chinese archives so one of the
webinars was on
introducing digital sources for chinese
history and one was on
introducing collections beyond the
traditional chinese
archive so they included collections in
the united states in taiwan
in japan and on so-called garbology
materials or materials that are found in
unconventional places
and we will drop the links for those
videos in the chat
so based on the responses to last year's
series
we decided to dedicate a full webinar
this summer
to taiwanese archives libraries and
databases
and in this session we are very lucky to
be joined by
four archivists and historians who will
be introducing a few
noteworthy collections from institutions
including academia cynica
academia historica and the national
archives administration
all of which hold copious materials not
just on taiwanese history
but on mainland chinese history as well
so let us
get started um today we are going to be
joined by david chung chung who is an
associate professor of
history at hong kong university of
science and technology
and david is going to be guest
moderating this session
david was really crucial for helping to
organize this webinar and we would
very much like to thank him as well as
at harvard university for helping to put
us in touch with our four
presenters um we are very grateful for
their help
um so we will turn it over to david now
who is going to introduce our speakers
and he will also be responsible
for moderating this session and handling
the q a
so david why don't you take it away okay
thank you emily for a generous
introduction
thank you for attending this webinar
and the reason i was invited to guest
moderate this event probably because
emily know that when i was in grad
school
we were both at uc san diego i only
spent
three days in prc archives and i spent
two years in taiwan doing archival
research
and oral history but of course i mean i
have to admit i did a lot of oral
history research
in in the mainland but only three days
in archives
so in taiwan this is really a treasure
trove
for people doing research on modern
chinese history
or today we're going to also uh dr
chancey
is going to speak about pre-modern
materials so it's a great place to do
research
you should really start your research in
taiwan
no matter what project you are on okay
now i'm going to introduce for
distinguished panelists
uh all four of them are historians and
the two of them are archivists
first we're going to have uh dr chen uh
uh who is a research fellow at the
institute of history and phenology
at the academia cineca and he's also the
director
at the center for digital cultures and
he received his phd from harvard
university and his research
interests are archival research and the
chain history
and next we're going to have dr xiaoy
ahom
at the institute of modern history
archives at
academia seneca and he is the archivist
there
and he received his phd from national
qinghua university
he formerly he worked at the academia
historical
that's why we're going to ask him to
also present on goshikone's holdings
and he also taught at the national
taipei university of
nursing and health sciences and national
defense medical center
so his research interests include modern
china nursing in taiwan
and archival studies next uh dr
from yuan at the national archives
administration
of the national development development
council
which is probably this organization
is going to become the equivalent to u.s
national archives that's my
understanding and he's going to
explain exactly how this archive
actually is becoming which is becoming
increasingly important
for any research and he received his
ph.d from national chelsea
university and he is also an assistant
professor at the foreign catholic
university
and suzhou university and his research
interests
include china's foreign relations thomas
and international organizations disease
prevention and treatment
and archival studies and he has
published numerous articles
and two books one of the books is a
wto and malaria prevention and treatment
in taiwan
another book the roc government in
nanjing
and the league of nations and finally we
come to our fourth speaker
uh dr chu anju
after the institute of modern history
of academia seneca and he received his
phd from brown university
right now he's finishing a book on the
construction of a trust
in examination in china and taiwan after
the 1905
abolition of the imperial exam system
koji
and after the presenters uh
presentations we're going to have about
roughly 20 minutes
of qna but you can type your questions
in q a box
anytime so probably you should type your
question along the way so
i moderate questions trying to get all
questions answered
you may choose to direct your question
to a specific speaker
or just a general question or if you
need help with the translation
uh either in chinese or english you can
type please translate i
try my best to type out the just the
translation but not that of course not
the simultaneous translation i type up
in the box okay
thank you now let's move on uh to dr
chancey dr chen please
hello everybody it's my pleasure to have
this opportunity to show you the
research and database for
synology in taiwan and thank you very
much for the invitation from the year
macmillan center council on east asian
study
because epidemic is occurring all over
the world not only the
state of international politics but also
the field academic
research has become more intense however
online database is still a good method
for researchers to connect our knowledge
and
taiwan online database can let you
assess another new world
um so today's lecture will focus on the
field of digital archive which we have
developed in the past 20 years in taiwan
as the current director look at the
silicon center for digital culture
a and cdc in this talk i will emphasize
more work
produced by acting cynical as well as
share some of my thoughts on historical
research
as my own research experiences
um before i begin my talk i would like
to answer the question
why on the boundary of the technical
skills used by historians
and especially in early 2020 john mcnell
former president of the american
historical association
said in terms of historical research the
golden age
of traditional documents is already past
its peak
the new age of his historical research
introduced a diversified historical
resource and the
research method this may be a time to
build up kind news
skills so i hope my lecture can give
everyone some assistance on this point
so the first one is i want to share with
you is about the china
taiwan digital archive the chinese
capitalization year lags the west by
30 years um but there's a two critical
automation project in taiwan so taiwan
was the first
in world to begin chinese text
digitalizing project
on the left you can see the photo can be
silicon general assembly
in 1984 when they first decided to
create a center
for computation technology the first
material to be digitalized
were the treaties on food and
commodities
a database uh of historical indoor
chinese corpora at the financial is a
historical database project
in the institute of history and
philology launch of construction of
the other full text database for
confusion tax history philosophy and
literary texts and so on
so taiwan become the leader in the
so-called chinese book database
in the early 1990s moreover the database
method of searching and
using traditional archive caused a
revolution
in the field of literature and history
research in taiwan
and even impacting technology over the
world
so this image from 2020 is one of our
center
for digital cultures collaborative
project developing
world segmentation and the part of
speech taking for chinese
you know corpus and
this is only the voting from text to
object so beside the digital text that
began
digitizing biological spacemen record
maps archaeology and anthropological
artifacts
and in image etc in terms of technology
we also began focusing on digitalization
standards
meta data specification and 3d modeling
and database management
this type of high integrated national
level digital archive project was
arguably unrivaled in word and time so
you can see a logo on the past project
on the left
and looking back on this period of
history we can see
nothing or not one arrived late to
digital trend of the modern world
inevitance quickly rose to to become one
not the pioneer of digital humanity
on the left at least you know just some
of the current a long time collaboration
with ncdc and we are always building new
partnerships
so this site summarize the time that i
just described so far
you can see that different goals were
pursued
during different time period today
i have you know inherited a digital
archive work
of my predecessors and continue to find
ways to seek
new breakthrough and we will take a look
at the current project
as cdc so first is the so-called
building
uh knowledge based and to do the tour
research
development and maintenance and we also
encourage
you know uh scholars from active seneca
to use digital humanities tools and
knowledge basis
to carry our research study and we also
produce both
physical and virtual publication making
humanity research
accessible through a variety of channels
an scdc has many excellent in our know
technical staff we research and develop
the tools to enable humanity research
to conduct research in a new and
efficient ways
especially when facing big data samples
so the fundraising
introduction to digital humanities
research tool developed by adam cynical
center for digital cultures
so there are two categories test
analysis research platform and
image analysis test uh in the platform
and i want to highlight this platform
you know this
list text analysis platform also a kind
of english
interface and so there's an example of
how you can use a digital hematic
research platform
you can search a text of the novel for
example the dream
and the red chambers for change in the
frequency of the world
expressing emotional content
and let's so-called the image analysis
system we developed
with w triple i f standards to close
platform compatibility
as well as function for image comparison
content regulation
etc
so the open museum we developed in in
recent years is a kind of vital space
that
intricate collection display and
application functions
the preference showcased at the silicon
research and
translate it into a wider audience
um my colleague
uh professor cusk you know he he
gathered you know 20 academic
uh humanity and science scholar on board
on a in a project funded by the rapid
resource
sponsor brand on kobe 19 and the social
scientist
within the few months the team composed
popularly
accessible science article foreign
launch of the you know reflection
on kobe 19 website this year on
companion books
published was printed on just five days
ago on july 15.
this book featured 19 articles by 20
humanities and social science scholar
whose work contributed a very valuable
knowledge to a terminus society
during this critical period now i will
introduce
four to one most important archive
institute as well as their most notable
database
so you can see you know um some
important digital archive instruments in
taiwan on the screen
like an agnes seneca national
touring university and national park
museum and national central library
if you look at the you know for you are
looking for classical chinese text
again the kanji in the super trans
cynical database is an excellent
resources and it was built by
ihp it cover a wide variety of
collections
over the past 30 years you have
collected chinese literature from
different
eras including a rare bookstore mention
historical material treaty
and chart and we also had the known
recircular veritable
record of the ming dynasty and qing
dynasty
and the korean joseon dynasty so for
example if you look for the information
regarding units you can see from the
ming channel that the ming dynasty
requests a unique from korea
and from the joseon dynasty record
you can also you know find history
record of the joseph dennis attributing
eunuch to the ming dynasty of course you
know the
narrative that the narration will be
different and
worst comparison
an active cynical you know um book
collection we put great effort to ensure
accuracy of the text so we can see on
the detailed
revision highlight in the red scripture
singing cinecom introduced access to the
major buddhist work
taisho nyong chiptaka so which i use
here
as an example now i would use an example
from the region that everyone may be
familiar with
the chinese on this historic building
here known as the yellow train tower
huankulo which is one of my research
topic
um so the strictest cynical database
collects
highly accurate texts on the traditional
catalogue of
jinxes and including downscan and the
buddhist literature
so we can find a painting and and many
other results
in a database we if you you do a keyword
search
for yellow crane tower so we can say
look what field we can want to
you know see through for example here i
can you know use the
the text name one and annotation
including alternative character spelling
each
so we can see the results showing
general author
title etc and we can also search the
catalog directly
by any keywords of which is highlight
who has appeared on the test
in the text so we can select different
text or even
addition of the syntax and compare them
using text comparison
function so we can even bring up the
digitalized image of the original text
to see how the original phrase appeared
then you can filter your research result
even more by searching for multiple
keywords
so like here that we just use the single
words like
use the bunker low and the fruit and the
immortals
so we can provide a kind of text
comparison function
so we can use another single word search
and we can use in the three key
you know keywords at the same time so we
can provide with the comparative
compressor function
the documents of isp scripted cynical
databases are integrated with the search
analysis platform so we can directly
search for organize a list of name
so people place an official positions
there is a deming yeah here i'll give
you an
example associated with the phone call
is wrong will show
um so the document of the hp
switch cinecom uh can you know can
make a hyperlink to
the database for official names which is
build
the in cooperation with the national
parks museum taipei
so database of wholesome main yeah so
you can see here
in taiwan the major databases that hold
the lack of ancient literature are shown
on this site
so they are you know including some
classica
an ihb digital archive online and
national policy museum database of rare
books and national central library
real books and spatial collection
database i won't go to the
detail you can take a look at it and
also you know you can compare with the
various kind of
chinese book database which uh i believe
everybody here you know
are familiar with a safari
from the sweetheart cynical hans is cool
we could also have some important
collections such as mentioned archival
transported from china
in the 4th of 1948 and the tide of the
chinese civil world was turned
so [ __ ] recommended that the
archaeological relics
of the institution of history and
philology of
islamical be relocated to taiwan so the
qin dan is a mentioned danish archive
that was transported
in a long route through beijing's
and finally ending in taiwan
so the archive of the grand secretariat
the niger danku
are put together by the institutional
history and
they collect a bounding of three hundred
and ten thousand
items including period decree imperial
added
memorial tribute calculus
and etc and you know
so how important are the grand secretary
archive i recorded a description
from the well-known historian fusionian
he said the archives
treasure in include private written
account
the limited knowledge for official
document alone
are unreliable to unveiled the reality
of dynasty
so all the particular truths could be
you know on earth in this
archive so this is the
database we've been watching this since
then 2001
so in the past century there has been
for example
uh in the past century there have been a
controversial consumer ascension
of young emperor to the throne one of
the key evidence of
pieces of evidence is the kanji
emperor's last testament which
stood in the [ __ ]
so this lisbon evidence
has drawn much attention from scotland
in this field
silva titled the last testament you can
find
uh the emperor conscience the last
testament
um so this is the kanji uh emperor lance
testament
which is clearly indicate the fourth
principle [ __ ]
was his chosen one
and we are also kind of robbing um
a collection of robins and institute
history and philology uh village
we have a large number of robbins or
variety dynasties and generations are
collected
including robbins of the royal bones
inscription
bronze whale robins han dynasty stone
relief robin's
body stone sculpture robins and lyan
jing yuan danish stone rabbits
so these precious arabians can be used
to compare the literature
passed down through generations to
better understand the ancient chinese
history and culture
regarding divination sacrificing
mythology
religion so on so forth
so this is a list of the robbing
collection in acting cinecom
modern of course in the modern chinese
uh history um
database also integrated together
several of them syndicates in a smaller
modern historical database and offered
convenient english
interface my colleague doctor sean at
home well i believe he will give you
uh details later here i just use an
example for
from my research if you search
the full market you can find the result
concerning martial
you know martial handicraft produced in
the imperial court of the qin dynasty
if you search for manchin you can see on
the screen
that the general xiu left behind many
records
to play mahjong during the world time
um john she was the representative of
the republic of china in 1945
at the signing of the instrument of the
surrounding of japan that ended world
war
ii and he also the ministry of a board
military operation
in 1949 and aside and outside the
academy cinecom
i want to introduce the kind of
attention it will briefly give you an
idea of the then which is database
by national town university and
from the document you can see the
relation between china and taiwan during
the qing rule
which is presented as central various
local government relationship
as well as structurally as a center
versus a peripheral
relationship so we can not only see the
archive to learn early chinese legal
history
local administrative history and social
economic history
but also to know the relation between
the administrative area taiwan and china
the picture keys of the archive recorded
about the gambling fraud
so above all the learning about taiwan
is not only
to know the aerial taiwan but also a
vital introduction into the history of
china
so we can see inter you know the
relation between taiwan and central
ghana all the time
so as a vivid map mergers such as this
no we could also find even the data
absolutely
about the merger side showing on this
map
um no um we we don't have the you know
um
speaker here to speak about the
collection in the national policy museum
so i i just gave a brief
idea about the qin archive
stored in the initial price museum
because the national parks museum
database of railbox has recently updated
his interface
to make it easier to research online
recon registering an account is required
to view
image at high resolution so preview
image are
actually quite already so data field and
the keywords provide also
quite comprehensive so we can again
search the the keyword left bunker
yellow plane tower here so information
from the image the poetry and treble
notes can be found
throughout the database
so as for the uh national central
library special collection the platform
requires a specific
name or book or author for or isbn for
research
so however you can still view the field
digitalize the image
from ancient books take the yellow queen
towel for example again
if you can find the name of a related
point or text from
other database you can use the
information to see
to search the national central library
spatial collection website with a copy
of the full
image
so let me give you a show you know a
conclusion remarks
um why i'm understating various kind of
the online open result in taiwan that
research can still
access this in a different situation on
the kobe 19.
as a humanities scholar i can help i
cannot help but
lead everyone to interest in this world
of digital humanity
how should god define themselves in the
past the well-known historian for cinema
wrote in his you know
uh he said that we
are not reader of books
so we are simply searching the heaven
above and underworld below
moving our hand and feel to seek thing
out
in the area of digitalization scholars
don't necessarily have to travel up and
down
the world to collect you know firsthand
material or
archaeological finding now with the vast
amount of digital archives and database
as well as the meditation
by digital tools these things are
themselves generating their own
hands and field through ai through
algorithm
etc that required us to put together
their connection
in a structured and contextualized way
furthermore different research
institute most must become able to
exchange their
data on the document digitally if we are
to
complement each artist's works and
findings
however with detail in a terribly
convenient database
you may want in this new era do is the
new historian
or do we only construct the construct on
manipulate big data
um you know masquerading as a knowledge
in this digital world and this is my
humble opinion that
in our upcoming brand new digital world
let's do a lot of unknown territory for
us to explode
thank you for listening thanks
thank you dr chen for this extremely
rich uh informative
presentation uh good news everyone if
you missed a lot of details
since he had to go very quickly i will
send out
email you the powerpoint he just
presented so
you can see all the links and all the
detail okay
great uh now we're going to move on to
our next speaker
dr julia holm of activa seneca's
modern institute archives yeah home
please
in february 1955 academica scenica
especially a terrific
preparatory committing for
the institution of modern history and
the environmental goating e
a renowned history to service its chair
the in new work of the community
including recruitment of research
personnel
formulation of a research plan
portion of chinese and western books
and the connection of history materials
from both official and prime
souls
institution of modern history
academically
in 1964 or less through its
fire ban the archives was
was temperature in 1958
eight three years after the info
is still of modern history was a
family as temperature
in 1988 the building was referral
built to house the materials the
institution has a collection after more
than
half a century of materials
complexion it contains important
original historical records
and the service a major responsibility
for
research and modern chinese history
the theramatic files
are the highlight of these
archives which contain continue
from offer office or
records from the latching
dynasty unique the republic of china in
taiwan
the including fights of the office in
charge of
foreign affairs is only yaman
the ministering of objective
affairs on the ministering of
foreign affairs of the north government
under the ministry of foreign affairs of
the republic of china in taiwan
the most governmental facts are
worth special attention coming the years
1912
to 1938 their death dive
into 48 categories
according to subject matters
important events from from along the
time china first
enter the public years such as the
past insert a
trap during the european world
signal russian relations
and the special meeting on trip
and the packing are all encoding
economical facts the economic affairs
constitution the largest standard set
of metal materials of
this archives and including the because
of the common message initiating
the ministry of aquaculture
and commerce the ministry of
interesting the ministering of
economic affairs and the documents found
via economic
off for trade after the
national governmental retreat to taiwan
there are important priorities called
material on the
economical development of republic of
china
and taiwan
you can uh for example economic affairs
is called community archives the
archives
are important modern technology and
institutional history materials the
record committee archives are
stored in three locations the archives
of
students of modern history
academic history and the second history
archives in nanjing china
personal papers
over the pen 10 years the focus of
our connection has gradually
shift from office document to
private papers other than personal
arguments of those who are
had important military and political
politician and the leading program
in finance and medicine we also
collect material of five
institutions engines in the group
and any materials that that can
can contribute to the study of modern
history
truth papers not only deepen
our understanding of the republican year
but also
so like on the early history of
academia scenica
for example personal papers
we have a data wrapped link
link was the linker sent ah ring was a
thing a
feature a visit chooses
a whole country by grand pro teaching
and the
research on philosophy and
playing a key role in the developer
of the military medicine system during
the
signal japanese war
inspectors are including latest
workers and the reference not for plan
research
now we have also accordingly a ktd
recording please pay
per uh about what's
economically professionally impossible
in taiwan
the white river control commission
projector
the commission not a higher
higher commission not only use modern
technology in water conversation
conversation project
but trains skillful tickets and
in church who moved with the national
government
first to the southwest during the signal
japanese war
another picture is the hawaii river
control
mission project the hawaii
river water control commission for short
machine materials for high during
engineering projects in the
19 uh union kingdom
the main stream of argue function
and the flow is the project
based on the firearm of the iq
cultural promotion commission
house and the archives this project
explains how modern hit china try to
provide our culture
during and after the second world
war the war
it will also end some 1000 more
agricultural experience through the
experience social network
system and the screen is number to 2000
in total
uh we knew a database
is military news angel database
the military news angel is
a fearless monkey of
the ministering of national defense
is a military background gave each other
events in produce handling news
in the viral photos especially from the
1915 through the 1970s
when taiwan was still under the
mainstream law
[Music]
by digital all all the news and the
pictures
this archives provides a vile platform
for studying military history and the
international relations during the cold
war
uh we have many uh maps
the map the map of
china provides maps of water
waterways and maps of the world
on others
the archives are
website and the email
or we raised the reading room
uh how monday to the five
day connection
online is free
the other archive responsory
in taipei academy
uh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
information
such a rich presentation actually from
his presentation we can see
a lot of books actually came out from
these archives especially
the recent new book by india tan
right and also way soon and also earlier
earlier book by nika mascarino so i mean
also my own book benefit from this
archive that goes
and changes all time but thank you now
let's go and move on to
uh dr shi fong yuan of the national
archive administration
how
oh
everyone my english is supposed so i
only can you use chinese to
to to say something um
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
what
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
um
foreign
foreign
huh
yeah this is so rich it's so
overwhelming i think people just say oh
how can i
keep up with this no worry we're going
to send this powerpoint to you you're
going to follow all the links
follow them follow the national archive
administration the future national nara
of
taiwan okay now let's move on to shu
anchu
dr chu
uh thank you david for the introduction
i would like to also thank
dennis and emily for putting the panel
together i also thank countdown for
putting me in touch with this
very dynamic group i appreciate this
chance to share my thoughts about doing
chinese history with materials in taiwan
and also doing chinese history in taiwan
as well
and as we have three very informative
presentations ahead so
i have to luxury to present in a less
informative way or somewhat random way
okay i was born and raised in hong kong
so taiwan or the republic of china has
never been
unfamiliar for me nor do i see the
republic of china as something in the
past tense
so the republic is still ongoing but
back then i did not know how relevant
this could be
to my own research and career i did my
master's degree on nation pure history
in taiwan on managing history
so i was attracted by the works of the
very strong cohorts of
late imperial scholars there here or a
china association syrian is definitely
one of the towering figures in death
field
but only after i started my phd in the
states
i started things serious about seriously
about the history of
the republic of china in taiwan after
1949.
at sprout i entered the modern china
field and worked with rebecca nadastop
my advisor and she had already started
her fascinating project
on displacement of both living people
and also dead bodies in mid
20th century china and taiwan so we read
we write documents together and and i
benefited a lot from her
over the course of my phd research i did
archival and library research in china
mostly the langjing second the circle
archive
library research in the u.s like i rely
heavily on
borrow direct so i can stay in brown and
then just go to worldcats and then
order the books that to be sent to our
library which is not particularly
not they don't have a very rich
collection of east asian books
and also at last taiwan but when i
started to write my dissertation i found
that the materials in taiwan do not just
support the existing research agendas
they do not just support existing
research questions
these materials in taiwan also change
the way how i
formulate my research questions how i
define the scope of
issues and actually quite fundamentally
change
how i paradise the 20th century chinese
and taiwanese history
so move on so
the question i came across was to how to
make sense of the republic of china
beyond 1949
putting the republic of china after 49
to the equation
can change a lot the question we ask
will no will be confined to something
like the cause of the 1949 tobacco
or how the wars aborted the development
during the launching decades
during the launching decade we can now
ask questions like
how did the roc the republic of china
republic of china government and vehicle
and with illegal regime that function
though with a lot of flaws and problems
for at least another three decades in
taiwan despite the wars
or the the wars in fact help to build
and consolidate
the system so we can ask very different
kinds of questions
and we have to have very different kinds
of prioritization scheme
so sometimes i would call this the long
republican period
and at last at the end i wrote a
destination that spanned from
1905 to 1980s and nearly one third of
this is about
post 1949 taiwan so from then on i do
not just do
chinese history in taiwan physically
presence in taiwan
but i also do chinese history in taiwan
the
history the chinese history of the
republic of china in taiwan
so that's why i choose to choose this is
the title of my presentation today
so for archival research we have where
fung yuen and yahoo have already done
a lot of heavy lifting so i should focus
on
some database and published materials
so the and but unfortunately and then
i also see this from some of the
questions raised by uh
race race in the chat room that about
about
where to find a hub or where to find a
go to website or go to
site to look at all these materials
at least kind of get a sense of where
these materials
are but unfortunately the post-49 book
collections
were actually quite scattered they
already formed their own special
collections
so i would in this in the following
presentation i will look at three
categories
instead of use using libraries as units
these genres of materials i think that
they give a sense that how and why
studying the republic of china
after 49 in taiwan is an intellectually
intellectually promising field or
intellectually promising project
the first kind of materials is related
to exportly divided legal materials and
then related to the
constitution the chinese constitution in
taiwan
so as you may know you may already know
that the constitution of the republic of
china is
is drafted in lunging and then
eventually migrate with the
nationalist government to taiwan after
49 so this is a
very interesting constitution in many
ways so it
it contained a very peculiar five power
system designed by sony ascent
so under the system there are two
different part two powers
outside of the three power uh
traditional free power system
so we have the acceleration power and
control power
which mode called the control power
which model after the
use the sensor system uh from late from
imperial china
so there are quite a lot of problems and
difficulties created by this
constitution
not only because this is a chinese
constitution made in china
and then taken to taiwan but because of
the this peculiar system of
five powers is a five power constitution
so to deal with these problems
so we have to with a long list of
interpretations by justice of the
judicial u.n
so the judicial branch of the republic
of china's government
so this is a there's a database so it's
something very
it may be something quite big in this
level but i still find it very
uh intellectually stimulating to look at
the
just interpret these interpretations it
covers not only those
constitutional level kind of problems
like territory or like the definition of
who is or who is not civil servant
because that's
quite problematic things under the
system of examination power
but you can also see a lot of very
interesting and everyday life things in
these interpretations
including the deceived the regulations
oversee
the regulations over adoption of
children
in civic law and then the licensing of
medical practitioners
so and so forth there's quite a lot of
different things in these
interpretations and also and then these
are all
open openly accessible online and then
you can see the hyperlink here
and also raise uh your uh draw attention
to another
uh system which is also from the
judicial un the judicial branch of the
roc government
and then this is called judicial u.n law
and regulations retrieving system
so that's that's a there's quite a
wealth of materials in this they have
cases and then completely searchable but
although sometimes
all those after they have updated their
system unfortunately
the search engine become less sensible
than i used it
two or three years ago but still there's
a there's quite a lot can be found in
these two sites uh these two databases
and then and then these bring drawstring
draw attention to
the specific or peculiar legal issues
arrays that
emerged after 49 in taiwan because of
the our
republic of china system so i will just
walk you through
the quantities the judge
justice interpretations so from 1949 to
present there are
in total 805 uh interpretations
so you can access it such as them in
full text
in from this website through this
website and then if you
they also have english version but if i
remember correctly they
have translation of 600 ish
of these interpretations so i think
that's this
and then there's a lot of quite
interesting materials in these
interpretations and then for me if
you want to look for some topics and
then relate
broadly related to china china and
taiwan
over the 20th century sometimes step
typically
this can be quite rewarding to take a
look at these interpretations
as well as and and also the judicial
experience website as well
okay i'll move on to then another kind
of
materials or another genre of materials
so the tongs young way
which is publication of native place
associations
so native place associations have been a
phenomenon in modern chinese
in latin pure and modern chinese history
but the publication
of native trade associations actually
proliferated after
after 49 and in the format of magazine
and they usually use the title like
something a particular province
and then when shield in this example
uber wins in
so these materials actually this tong
xiang way
is actually some kind of institutions
that
shape and also reproduce identities
chinese identities
after 49 quite important in this sense
so how where to find these kind of
materials
are draw attention to gosha sugun the
national central library
they have a second one since this new
one which is the
database of taiwan periodicals so
back in the days i love the function of
browse by issue of this uh goes out to
sugar and c conversation one but sadly
uh their recent renovation of the recent
updates of their system
they cancel this function so you cannot
just press
the particular issue of a particular
periodical
and then find find the titles of the at
least you cannot have a look at the
titles of the
of the of the art of the articles but
you cannot do it anymore but
still what are those who want to see
kind of when sentences you want if you
don't want to look
if you know what to look for and you if
you know something about the keywords
about the titles
of the kind of periodicals you want to
look for still
still is the go to database this still
is a table place to go to first
before you do further research and then
i also know that there's a
recent sudoku constructed by mainland
china
china company so
so it is called taiwan somewhere cool
so they provide partial uh
part you it requires subscription but
you can pass these access to the type of
contents of these magazines
through this uh through this uh database
and still and then so i i i
i i watched the i watched one of the one
of the
i watched one of the youtube videos of
the of the last
last series and then i thought i think
that was jeremy brown
he walked us through of he walked us
through
the confused website about how to use
auction websites to
conduct preliminary research with
materials especially post-49 materials
so i also think that this also works
well with taiwanese taiwanese materials
after 49
so auctions websites in taiwan you have
routine
you also have yahoo
yahoo paimai those are auction websites
actually you can find quite a lot of
good stuff there
so i also so then i'll also walk you
through
one of the issues of this ruby once and
give you a sense of how it what it
looked like in these kind of magazines
by published by native players
associations so
as you can see it's not very it's not
always informative
for historians so it provides a lot of
underdogs
a lot of um a lot of personal
recollections
they may not be firsthand with
materials but sometimes they provide a
lot of unexpected help
for researchers but i personally find
the biographies most helpful
in this category in this genre of native
place association magazines
so you can see at the bottom you have
seen highways
highway sensing under a biography of
highway
highway is not a very famous scholar but
actually play a very important part in
the
introduction of iq tests and
standardized tests into china and taiwan
and then his career spanned from
mainland to taiwan so he is quite a
for my own research is quite important
but you can but he's not he's quite an
obscure person so you cannot find it you
can it's difficult to find his biography
or biographical information but this
issue of the hubei one sense safe say to
be so
sometimes you can see biographies a lot
of very
of very interesting and important people
from this um from this native phase
price black magazines
and then that's what that's going to be
extremely useful for researchers
and then for more than i'm not sure if
that's true for
other modernist modern chinese scholars
but for me
who work from latin period to modern
time period
i find that is sometimes difficult to
find a
stable pool of biographies uh for more
than more than
for for figures for for individuals in
the modern period
so in the main chain period we have so
those go to
source books we have the dictionary
biography we have the
word for the for the for the main chain
text we have the uh
we have the face on z we have those kind
of regular
source book or two book to go to or
later the jojo's rules mean
johnson with those kind or or later we
have with the
chainway we mentioned constructed by the
series
but for modern history historians it's
different it's sometimes
difficult to locate someone especially
some obscure person
uh biography biographical information so
i think that
the native place association magazine
maybe
maybe it can provide some help in this
regard
okay then i move on to the third kind of
materials i find it very interesting and
then
tells us a lot of the intellectual
promise about
doing chinese history after 49 in taiwan
so it's called the facing ngo or
literally translated as research on
communist bandits
so this is also
for obvious reason this is also a genre
which proliferated after
49 so unfortunately this
again this this kind of materials or
this kind of folks are not very
uh we don't have we do not have a very
focused specialized uh
collection of this but uh the good thing
is that uh in
in the coding library of of of my own
of my home institution the i'm imx
institute of modern history
we have a section with a zero zero
section
in this library that's actually that's a
small room on the first floor of the
continuing library you can see nearly
all these
uh all these uh all these uh
facing angel related books stored in
that
room so that's quite helpful if
someone have the chance to look at have
to have the chance to visit
coding library it's quite it can be
quite rewarding to just to browse
through the stack
and then it's some sometimes it's
provide a lot of
inspiration just to browse browse
through the stacks
instead of using directly using the
database
another place for this kind of like
another hub
for this kind of faking angel materials
i think that this should be the
libraries of natural challenges like
changing university chengda has been one
of the center for facing ngo or
jungle yeah for a very long time so they
have a lot of discount materials
but unfortunately those materials are
stored in different libraries
different fungus in so you have to have
a sense of
what to look for before going there so
these are the two
places i can think about if you want to
situate or want to locate uh 180
materials
again i i recommend going to auction
websites
and then to do preliminary research like
going to the computer to
look for materials post 49 materials
or at least have a sense of what it
looked like
before before further further research
because
there's there's quite a lot of things
put online and to be sold these days
and then they then the sellers often
provide pictures
a table of contents that can be helpful
by itself
no matter your purchases purchases or
not so i also recommend going to
auction websites and then if you want to
look for
this kind of facing angel materials
once again those these facing angel
materials
are not something can be used as
first-hand materials on
especially on plc history but for me
is they're extremely useful to
reconstruct
the information circuits between the
between roc republic of china and plc
to ideologically or politically
confronting
regimes they're supposed to they're
supposed to be detached from each other
during the cold war
but if you look closer at this at this
facility materials you can still see
there's a information circuit
working over over the code over the cold
war so this is something i'm very
interested in
and then in one of my recent site
projects i
i look at i look at the simplification
character project in taiwan
so usually we think that taiwan use uh
traditional characters chinese
characters and then the plc
they have their simplified characters
but actually there's a lot of ongoing
efforts to
simplify to or to introduce simplified
characters
uh in taiwan over the 50s 60s and 70s
during the so during the so-called
authoritarian rule
so that's quite strange and then
actually there's a lot of common ground
between the intellectuals in taiwan
and then in mainland china in terms of
simplified characters
so this is something i read from
wangsutiere
diary and then he read this beijing
yanzhou book
and then he didn't just read it as a
condemnation of
the way the communist bandits destroy
chinese culture in china
but actually took it very seriously it
took that took those
information in these books seriously as
possible
projects or alternative projects to
simplify chinese characters
and then these projects can give
resource to him to
think about the way characters can be
simplified in taiwan so
that's something quite counter intuitive
that's that they're not confronting with
virtual issues they actually borrow
resources from intellectual resources
from from each other
so one system has a long history as i
cite here has a long history of
doing simplification since the days in
mainland so he
he has ongoing interest for the
simplification of chinese characters
even after moving to taiwan after 14
nights so that's something i find
quite interesting and that's something i
also find useful
in this kind of 18 angel materials
okay so time one time is running short
so i will
end my presentation with a piece a piece
of material that i find interesting
recently and this material itself
tells a lot of story tells a story about
how books not just people my grades but
also how books
and then by grades and how books how the
reproduction and then
how the reproduction of books can tell
stories about
the republic of china in taiwan
after 49. okay the book i'm dealing with
is is called jungle services dependency
a historical analysis of the chinese
society
by tao si sung tao zi-sung as you may
know he's a very famous
politician and also scholar is the
founder of the so-called super
school of social history and economic
history there's a lot of influence in
post-war taiwan
both pre-49 mainland chinese
historiography
also is also a strong influence over
people scholars historians in
in the in the academic in taiwan after
49.
so this is one of these minutes
yeah okay so i'll just wrap up okay so
this is a book written by him
so we have the type type edition and
then
we also have the paging edition but if
you just look at the paging edition
you you'll miss a lot of things here
which is
first this is a book we when tau season
one we published his book
he didn't have a copy with him in the
50s so he borrowed one from
the taita collection and then the title
collection actually
got got from the tai hokku imperial
university collection
so this collection was acquired uh this
book was acquired in the
probably in the 20s or 30s by the data
the imperial universities so that's
quite interesting quite uh
for someone the over the over himself
lost the audio copy
but he retrieved this copy from this uh
from
and so-called enemies collection and
then
actually this collection i think the
most important takeaway is that
this book this copy is completely
accessible through the taiwan
ebook database so you can see on the
right hand uh right top top right corner
you see
the the seal of the type a
university so that's quite interesting
for me because
usually if you want you you assume that
you have to go into the
special collection to look for this
problem number of bamboo of additions
but sometimes if you browse through this
database
i think that's a very just type of
taiwan ebook database is quite a
generous web
generous database it provides a lot of
very useful and very valuable
books and then with high resolution
upload completely online so this one
this is one of the examples so this book
also tells a lot of stories and then
but i don't have time to the republican
of this book actually i think that's
quite interesting but i don't have time
to move on
but just give me one more minute for the
final final final wrap up
so the point i want to make with these
materials and this entire season scope
is that so the text the books
the materials in taiwan they not just
provide alternatives
choices of materials to do chinese
history
but also they significantly change the
way we frame our questions about chinese
history
and then change the way we paradise
change the scope of
doing chinese history so i think that is
i think that it will be very rewarding
to
look into the stories of these books why
and how
they eventually exist in taiwan
and then they can bring that can that
that can be very
intellectually rewarding so that's my
general most general general
uh point one two i want to make with
this presentation thank you for your
attention
great thank you dr chu for your thought
for a reflection
uh now we have where over time so
we just uh over done 905
let's we have five minutes left for q a
but i want to do it very quickly
did some of the questions have been
answered uh in the
in the chat uh in the q a box you can
look at them
and the remaining questions i think
there are around few themes
number one i think chuan also mentioned
this it um
and and madeline don don't you ask this
question is there a central platform or
convenient
clearinghouse with links to all archives
and showing
that which also shows which ones are uh
we can access online
so
your audio
yeah not exactly um that's a very
similar question to
spencer's question which i answered that
you know is there a kind of
reference site or in indexing websites
for
compiling all the digital database
as a matter of fact the lesser kind of
so-called taiwan union catalog
they so-called t-i-i-e
uh uc which i put in my answer to
uh lou spencer's question i mean it's a
kind of portrait to tell in the database
so this is called digital taiwan so you
can use the digital terminal
it's kind of uh taiwan chang it's kind
of research for showcase platform
you know built by my my center so it's
kind of browse for catalog
and you can know about it all the
digital knowledge bases about taiwan
so you can you know to be with to begin
with you can
use this kind of taiwan union catalog to
start your research
yeah this message yeah just in the
answer to q a yeah so
everyone can look at that
well done
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
if it's digitized you'll receive a a cd
rom right a cd
disk they're going to mail it to you
yeah at the cost of it two
new common dollars per page which is
very cheap
yeah uh so you go into okay the last
question is about
uh mainland research right uh
one user is asking about early state
building period land reform in mouse
china between 49 and 56
i think xuan or the answer partial
answer that's right 15 yen jio
that's one of the sources but what what
else
you muted it
as well
foreign so his point is that there is
some overlapping right between the
institute of uh modern history archives
and to the national archives
demonstration so some there are some
overlap
so you might you might get them from
uh okay there are still some questions
but
we don't have time we're out of time so
thank you everybody for joining us
and uh thank all the panelists so if you
have more questions
please write to them you'll receive the
email
with the link to the youtube recording
according to those talks and also their
powerpoints
and their email so you can write to them
and
emily so on behalf of myself and emily
i want to be a final thank you to
everyone you're definitely over time uh
but
uh seeing how little attrition there is
among the attendees i think that
everyone that is like me feeling
inspired and motivated not just to do
this research but to
to come visit taiwan someday soon um
thank you to david for moderating
everyone
all the panelists for being both
archivists and historians and models to
us all in performing this
this great service to our field and our
students um
i also want to thank the council
appreciation studies at yale especially
stephanie kim and richard sosa for for
providing all of the support
and background for this event and thank
you to all the participants for tuning
in
this evening uh please note that our
next
and final webinar in this series will be
on thursday august 12th
at 8 00 pm eastern on the topic of
academic jobs outside the united states
you will have to register for that
webinar in order to receive the new link
specific webinar
it's not the same link as this webinar
so we'll
we'll send that registration link in the
chat thank you all for tuning in
uh we'll see you in a couple of weeks
and thank you to everyone who presented
today
see that's good bye